I’m going to start
today with a question.
In other contexts,
perhaps, a risky question,
not one you would expect
from somebody in my position
in a talk about climate change.
But it's important.
Does size matter?
(Laughter)
My answer, perhaps also unexpected,
is that no, it really, really doesn't.
(Laughter)
And Scotland --
(Applause)
Scotland is proving that.
About a mile from here,
in the National Museum of Scotland,
you will find on display a steam engine
designed by the great engineer James Watt.
A hundred miles from here,
just off the coast of Aberdeen,
is the world's biggest floating wind farm.
And then just a bit further north
from there, in the Pentland Firth,
we find the biggest
wave power turbine being tested.
These are all extraordinary feats
of technology and engineering,
but they also demonstrate
how Scotland, a relatively small country,
led the world into the Industrial Age
and is now helping to power the world
into the Net-Zero Age.
And there's a lesson for us in that.
When we talk about
tackling climate change,
we so often talk about the contributions
of America, Russia, China, Brazil,
and that's important.
We won't limit global warming
without these countries,
but we also have to recognize
that the ambition, the leadership
and the action of small countries
matters too.
Small countries have no time
for small objectives,
and I really agree with that.
And we see examples of the leadership
that small countries show
everywhere we look.
Take Bhutan.
One million people or thereabouts
became the first in the world
to commit to being
carbon-neutral for all time.
Since then, 130 countries of all sizes
have followed suit.
Or Fiji.
In 2017, it hosted
the UN Climate Conference
and did so much to highlight
the existential threat
that climate change poses
to island nations.
Now, a country like Scotland
with a rich industrial past
has a special responsibility.
We have disproportionately
contributed to climate change,
so we must do more now
to help tackle climate change.
So in recent years,
Scotland, this small country,
has decarbonized faster
than any G20 country.
We have just become --
(Applause)
We have just become
the first nation in the world
that is not an independent nation --
yet -- to publish --
(Laughter)
(Applause)
to publish
an indicative, nationally
defined contribution
showing how we will meet
the objectives of the Paris Agreement.
So we've pledged to cut emissions
by three quarters by 2030
and to be net zero by 2045.
We're also seeking to galvanize
change on the global stage.
So we are currently
the cochair of a coalition
that brings together 200 states, regions,
devolved countries like ours
to demonstrate leadership in meeting
the challenge of climate change.
Now that coalition is not represented
formally at UN summits,
we are not signatories to the treaties
that emerge from these summits.
But collectively, we represent
two billion people across the world,
and about half of the reduction
in global emissions that we need to see
will depend on the actions we take.
They will depend
on the legislation we pass,
the infrastructure we build,
the investments we fund.
So my point today is that,
yes, big countries matter,
but the leadership
of small nations matters too.
It's often states and regions
and small nations that can step in
when the bigger countries fail to act.
So when Trump disgracefully
took America out of the Paris Agreement,
it was a coalition of states and cities
that kept the momentum going.
And if we raise our ambition
and if we follow that through with action,
then we can spark the bigger countries
to go further and faster, too.
And there's one final point where
our voice and our contribution matters.
So often it's states
or devolved nations like Scotland
that have to respond most directly
to the impacts of climate change:
heatwaves, floods, hurricanes.
We have to deal with the implications.
Now, for Scotland,
California and New South Wales
that's difficult but manageable.
For many others
across the world, it is not.
So climate justice matters, too.
It’s not enough to cut our own emissions,
although that is vital;
we have to make sure we are helping those
who have done the least
to cause climate change
to do so too.
And with the spirit
of justice and fairness
absolutely at the heart of that.
So to conclude, my message today is
that countries of all shapes and sizes
must step up to this challenge.
We cannot allow our size
to be something that we hide behind.
When it comes to tackling climate change,
size really, really does not matter.
We must think big in our ambition.
We must act big in what we do,
and we must be big
when it comes to the impact we make.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Bruno Giussani: First Minister, thank you.
I would like to ask a couple of questions
because you mentioned
the wind farms up north,
but there is a new field
opening up in the north,
it is an oil field, the Cambo oil field.
It’s been licensed
by the UK government,
and a few weeks ago
you wrote to the prime minister
of the UK government,
and you asked him to reassess
that field and the licensing
in view of the climate emergency.
There's also a growing movement
in Scotland against that project.
What are people to make
of opening up a new gigantic oil field
while at the same time pushing
for decarbonizing policies at COP?
Nicola Sturgeon: I think people are right
to ask big questions and be concerned.
Oil and gas is important to Scotland.
It has been for four, almost five decades
important to fulfilling our energy needs,
but it's important to our economy.
But if we're not prepared
to ask ourselves the hard questions,
we're not really
facing up to this challenge.
We can't switch
fossil fuels off overnight,
but we must accelerate
the transition away from them.
And therefore the question is:
Is new exploration consistent with that?
And that's the question
I posed to the prime minister
where the power over this lies.
Yes, we need to make sure that we make
the transition sustainably and fairly.
But if we just rely on new exploration
of the old ways of doing things,
I think the question is whether we do that
at the pace we are required to do.
So a country like Scotland,
we can't just answer the easy questions.
We've got to face up
to the hard questions as well.
But we must make sure
the transition is just --
just for people, for communities
and for the planet as a whole.
And that's what we are
committed to seeking,
to show leadership on.
BG: What was your exact demand?
Redraw the lines? Suspend it?
Change it? Reanalyze it?
NS: Well, the license
was granted 20 years ago.
There is a process
now it has to go through
to get approval for development.
And my argument is
just if a company was now applying
for a new licence,
there would have to be
a climate compatibility check.
Now, arguably that's not robust enough,
but the same thing should happen
if our existing license
is turned into development consent.
And that's the process
I think should happen.
We've got to be careful
that we don't leave communities
and people behind in that transition.
We've got to be careful
we don't switch domestic production
to imports of oil and gas.
That would be counterproductive.
So the way in which
we make the transition matters.
But we can’t have a business as usual.
Because if we keep telling ourselves
we can rely on fossil fuels forever,
then we'll never meet that transition.
And that's the key point
I think we've got to address.
BG: Let's hope it goes in that direction.
First Minister,
thank you for coming to TED.
Thank you.
(Applause)